>> Tucker: HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT UFOs, THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT HAS VERIFIED THEY ARE
REAL AND A SENSE THAT THERE'S
OBJECTS MOVING IN THE SKY THAT
WE CANNOT IDENTIFY, THEY ARE
CERTAIN THEY DO NOT BELONG TO A
FOREIGN NATION, THEY ARE NOT
FROM RUSSIA OR FROM CHINA.
AND THIRD WE KNOW THAT THESE
OBJECTS ARE MOVING IN WAYS THAT
WE CANNOT REPLICATE, EXPLAIN, OR
EVEN UNDERSTAND.
EVERYONE WHO STUDIED THIS IN THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT WILL ADMIT THAT
PRIVATELY.
NO ONE IS REALLY SAID THAT OUT
LOUD, AND THAT MAY CHANGE VERY
SOON.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HALF A
CENTURY, THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC
HEARING ON UFOs.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL HEAR FROM
TWO PENTAGON OFFICIALS TOMORROW
ON WHAT THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY KNOWS ABOUT THESE
OBJECTS, DEPENDING ON THE INTEL
AGENCIES REPORTEDLY FEUDING
TONIGHT ON HOW MUCH THE PUBLIC
SHOULD KNOW.
A MAN WHO DOES NOW, THIS PROGRAM
LOOKING INTO THESE, HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WHAT COULD POSSIBLY
BE THE JUSTIFICATION FOR HOLDING
BACK FROM THE PUBLIC WHAT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT, WHICH THE
PUBLIC PAYS FOR, KNOWS ABOUT
THESE OBJECTS?
>> IN FACT, IT MIGHT NOT BE WHAT
WE KNOW, TUCKER, BUT THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T KNOW SOME THINGS.
CLEARLY FROM A NATIONAL SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE, THE LAST THING YOU
WANT TO DO IS EVER BROADCAST
YOUR INTELLIGENCE GAPS TO YOUR
ENEMY.
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, HE
SAID IT YOURSELF, THERE'S A LOT
MORE WE DON'T KNOW THAT WE DO
KNOW.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, THIS IS A
HISTORIC MOOD.
SINCE 50 YEARS AGO, THE LAST
TIME WE ARE FACED WITH THIS
COMING OF THE AIR FORCE BRIEFING
THE RESULTS OF PROJECT BLUE
BOOK.
HERE WE ARE HALF A CENTURY LATER
AND NOW WE HAVE SEEN YOUR DoD
OFFICIALS NOW, NOT JUST THE
AIR FORCE, COMING UP AND
PROVIDING INFORMATION TO
CONGRESS AND ULTIMATELY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU KNOW IF
THERE HAVE BEEN CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN AMERICAN OFFICIALS AND
THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN SAY,
RUSSIA AND CHINA OVER THESE?
THEY ARE NOT JUST SPOTTED AROUND
U.S. MILITARY INSTALLATIONS, BUT
ALSO IN THOSE COUNTRIES AND
AROUND THE WORLD, DO EVER TALK
TALK ABOUT THIS OFF-LINE?
>> LET ME GIVE YOU A REAL
EXAMPLE, A VERY CLASSIFIED
MEMORANDUM BACK IN THE 60s
THAT THE UNITED STATES AND
RUSSIA AGREED IN WRITING THAT WE
WOULD REPORT TO EACH OTHER WHEN
WE WERE LOOKING AT THE NORTHERN
TIER, MAKING SURE THAT NEITHER
ONE OF US THOUGHT THE OTHER WAS
SHOOTING A NUCLEAR WEAPON AT THE
OTHER.
THIS IS SMALL PARAGRAPH THAT
SAYS LOOK, IF YOU HAPPEN TO SEE
A UFO, DO US A FAVOR, CALL US
FIRST BEFORE YOU PRESS THE
BUTTON, BECAUSE IT MAY VERY WELL
BE JUST THAT, A UFO, AND NOT US.
I THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN
EXAMPLES OF THAT WHERE WE HAD
INFORMATION SHARING WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES, SOME CASES OTHER
COUNTRIES -- AND A LAW PASSED
RECENTLY THAT WASN'T SPONSORED
BY SENATOR MARCO RUBIO WHERE IT
SAYS NOW WE ARE ENJOYING -- WE
MUST, WE HAVE TO WORK WITH OUR
FRIENDS AND ALLIES ON THIS
TOPIC.
IT'S NO LONGER AN OPTION.
WE HAVE TO DO IT.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE ANSWERED
YOUR QUESTIONS.
ONE, THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS HAD
FULL AWARENESS OF THIS FOR 60
YEARS.
THIS WAS IN THE 1960s YOU
SAID.
AND SECOND, WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN
THESE ARE NOT FOREIGN MILITARY
AIRCRAFT.
>> MULTIS MANUS, I SUSPECT THERE
WILL BE MORE HEARINGS AFTER THIS
PRAYER THIS IS JUST ESTABLISHING
THE BASELINE FOR CONGRESS.
BUT WE KNOW AGAIN ABOUT PROJECT
BLUE BOOK, WE KNOW ABOUT SOME
EFFORTS BEFOREHAND, AND WE KNOW
ABOUT MY PROGRAM.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE 40 SOME YEARS
IN BETWEEN?
WHAT OTHER EFFORTS TO THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT HAVE?
WHAT DID WE LEARN IN THAT TIME?
AND IS THERE WAY WE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION NOW UNDER A SINGLE
TENSE SO WE ARE NOT, IN ESSENCE,
REINVENTING THE WHEEL.
WE COULD COMPARE AND CONTRAST
INFORMATION AS COMPARED TO WHAT
WE ARE LEARNING WITH MORE
CAPABLE EQUIPMENT.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AN
INHERENTLY SIGNIFICANT STORY.
YOU PERSIST